hello everyone so now that we have an
intuition for what divergence is trying
to represent let's start actually
drilling in on a formula and the first
thing i want to do is just limit our
perspective to functions that only have
an x component or rather where the
the y component of the output is just
zero
so this is some kind of vector field and
if there's only an x component what this
means is going to look like is all of
the vectors only go left or right and
there's kind of no up or down
involved in any of them so in this case
let's start thinking about what positive
divergence of your vector fields might
look like near some point x y
so if you have your point you know this
is the point x y somewhere sitting off
in space
two cases where the divergence of this
might look positive are one where
nothing happens at the point right so in
this case
p
would be equal to zero at our point
but then to the left of it things are
moving to the left meaning p
the you know the x component of our
vector valued function is negative
right that's why the x component of this
vector is negative but then to the right
vectors would be moving off to the right
so over here p would be positive
so this would be an example of kind of a
positive divergent circumstance where
only the x component is responsible and
what you'll notice here this would be p
starts negative goes zero then becomes
positive so as you're changing in the x
direction p should be increasing so a
positive divergence here seems to
correspond to
a positive partial derivative of p with
respect to x and if that seems a little
unfamiliar if you're not sure how to
think about you know partial derivatives
of a component of a vector field um i
have a video on that and you can kind of
take a look and refresh yourself how you
might think about this partial
derivative of p with respect to x and
once you do hopefully it makes sense why
this specific positive divergence
example corresponds with a positive
partial derivative of p
but remember this isn't the only way
that a positive divergence might look
you could have another circumstance
where let's say
your point x y
actually has a vector attached to it so
this here again uh represents our point
x y
and in this specific example this would
be kind of p is positive p of x y is
positive at your point there but another
way that positive divergence might look
is that you have things coming in
towards that point and things going away
but the things going away are bigger
than the ones coming in but again this
kind of exhibits the idea of p
increasing in value you know p starts
off small it's a positive but small
component and then it gets bigger and
then it gets even bigger so once again
we have this idea of positive partial
derivative of p with respect to x
because changes in x as you increase x
it causes an increase in p seems to
correspond to positive divergence and
you can even look at it if you go the
other way where you have
a little bit of negative component to p
here so p is a little bit negative but
to the left of your point it's really
negative and then to the right it's it's
not nearly as negative and in this case
it's kind of like as you're moving to
the right as x is increasing you start
off very negative and then only kind of
negative and then barely negative and
once again that corresponds to an
increase in the value of p as x
increases so what you'd expect is that a
partial derivative of p that x component
of the output with respect to x is going
to be somewhere involved in the formula
for the divergence of our vector field
at a point x y and in the next video i'm
going to go a similar line of reasoning
to see what should go on with that y
component